finance ministers discussed our proposal  to establish a European fund for  strategic investments at their council  meeting in Brussels the plan is to  mobilize at least three hundred fifteen  billion euro in private and public  investment after tearing the talks  latvia's janice rares confirmed plans to  reach an agreement as early as next  month within the council maintaining a  schedule that should enable new  investment to begin in mid-2015 i  believe that we have good grounds for a  cautious optimism the grooves in the you  this year is going to increase reaching  one point seventy five percent the  council discussed growth prospects and  macroeconomic imbalances under the  European semester the e u--'s annual  policy monitoring exercise it adopted  conclusions as part of the process that  will lead to country specific  recommendations to the member states in  July 2015